yeah so I mean I wonder whether it might
be more helpful to move away from the
moralization of this discussion because
I was thinking about what was said
earlier in the panel there's 12 of the
world that shares this View and 88 that
doesn't and the question is not why does
the 88 not share this view is that
because they're stupid is that because
they're immoral is that because there's
something about the Western stance on
this conflict and the moralization of
the conflict that doesn't sit well with
the kind of double standards when it
comes to assessing morally conflicts
around the world that doesn't resonate
with actually the majority of the
world's population that isn't
represented around this table and isn't
represented in this theater but is there
and the question is what is their point
of view it's not about the East and West
it's about the majority and the minority
88 you don't know that 88 believe that
the ukrainians should lay down and die
you don't know that and SEC and and
since they are also human beings I have
to assume that if Oxana went to to to
Shanghai and had an event and told her
story she would find much sympathy and
support secondly 88 99 of people can
believe something and still be wrong and
one percent of the world can believe
something and still be right by
supporting the ukrainians and by
fighting the Russians one is not
ignoring neglecting or endorsing the
long history of colonialism that
preceded it but every single time I
choose to order a meal I cannot be
expected to deal with the problem of
colonialism there are times when one has
to deal with this but there are also
emergencies in history and when there
are emergencies whatever the past was
whatever the past was if I am the son of
Holocaust Survivors if Germany is
attacked by Putin I will support them
and I will not sit there and say well
well it's complicated for me because
they murdered my family and so on that
is not any way to proceed
you cannot not reduce
the
Holocaust to this war this war has
nothing to do with Holocaust this war
has nothing to do with schwa this is and
has nothing to do also with colonialism
this war is a a war between two
nationalism uh two two yes
[Applause]
because what I think Donatello is
talking about is not that the Ukrainian
should lie down and die
I think what you're talking about tell
me if I'm wrong is that there's a place
for negotiation and reason that ought to
be an alternative now but this is where
I am American historian
on January 20th 1961 John F Kennedy
famously said right let us not negotiate
not let us not negotiate out of fear but
let us not ever fear to negotiate
that
never fear to negotiate but we should
never negotiate out of fear
and I think what's going on today is
that we're being asked to negotiate out
of fear that is precisely what the
Russians are doing not just with this
but what was discussed earlier
all of the nuclear threats all of that
stuff that's going on here
take it for what you will it is
injecting fear
it is expecting us to negotiate out of
fear that is not a position I mean there
is such a thing as you know good will
seriousness moral seriousness but also
political seriousness
and I don't see that here what I see is
that they were being pushed to the
negotiating table
in a completely false way because it's
not about negotiation it's it's it's
it's just not